this is devante chisholm reading for
reviewer darren bontes tiny tina's
wonderlands isn't the first time that
first person shooter franchise
borderlands has delved into the realm of
high fantasy
developer gearbox software initially
explored this genre in the borderlands 2
dlc turned spin-off tiny tina's assault
on dragon keep back in 2013. almost a
decade later gearbox is venturing back
into the tabletop board game of bunkers
and badasses for a self-contained tale
of swords sorcery and stories while it
has inherited a number of the more
annoying borderlands quarks wonderland's
is still a comfortably familiar
experience that wears its passion for
tabletop gaming on its sleeve
thank you for saving my peasant ass
stranger how can i ever repay you
free of charge
i'm looking for the dragon lord tiny
tina is once again calling the shots as
the bunker master and alongside the
characters of valentine and fred voiced
by andy sandberg and wanda sykes it's up
to you to become the fatemaker who is
destined to save the land from the
menace of the evil dragonlord
borderlands has always had a strong
connection to the rpg genre and its deep
and varied character builds so a swerve
from a post-apocalyptic sci-fi to a
totally opposite field of fantasy isn't
jarring and in fact
meshes naturally with the loot and shoot
gameplay of gearbox's popular franchise
this is still a borderlands game at its
core and if you spent a few hours
scouring the planet of necro to feo
looking for typhon de leon audio logs
and fending off malawan troopers in
borderlands 3 then that muscle memory
will quickly kick in when you start
playing wonderlands every aspect of
wonderland is familiar but with tiny
tina's visual redesign layered on top of
it forget about shields you're protected
from some harm thanks to various wards
although there are still guns grenades
are out replaced instead with a book of
rechargeable spells that give you the
ability to live-action role-play a
fireball into a goblin's face or tear
the ground asunder with dark magic might
artifacts rings and necklaces confirm
more bonuses on your character and as
you'd expect from borderlands there's an
arsenal of weapons out there for you to
collect and experiment with the
wonderland stockpile doesn't fully
commit to the bit though as outside of
the fantasy facelift these guns still
perform as you'd expect them to gun
manufacturer brands such as doll vladoff
and bandits still feature the same
characteristics as their borderlands 3
counterparts while newer brands such as
swift arkhan and bonk give you
protective magical and melee options
remember you can't go wrong with a bonk
mace that slot from melee combat is an
intriguing addition to the meat and
potatoes gun play that wonderland has
inherited from borderlands getting up
close and personal with enemies in
previous borderlands games was a risky
tactic reserved for characters with
suitable skill trees like zero and krieg
but in wonderlands it pays to focus on
making certain that your sword is just
as sharp as your sorcery combined with
the long distance gun play wonderland
has a satisfyingly chunky rhythm to its
chaotic action once you've invested some
time in growing your fatemaker skills
after a few hours i found my groove and
felt like a warrior of legend i'd charge
into the thick of battle slide my way in
with the machine gun and unleash
freezing bolts of action in my path
following up with enemy shattering blows
from my cleaver a snap of my fingers to
cast armor melting acid bomb spells and
quick activation of my action skill to
polymorph a troll into a very confused
sheep
and i was a force to be reckoned with on
the battlefield just don't expect your
character builds in wonderland to hit
the same level of godlike power that the
vault hunters of borderlands 3 were
capable of hitting while every member of
borderlands troop had three skill trees
to pour a considerable number of skill
points into four if you purchased the
designer's cut of the game the
fatemaker's classes have a more singular
focus and comparison each of the game's
six classes is highly tuned to focus on
a key fantasy archetype and once you've
sunk some time into growing your fate
maker you'll soon be able to wield the
power of an additional class for example
the spell shot class is a dab hand at
firing spells and stacking buffs to
increase the power of these arcane
skills and when combined with the glass
cannon skills of the graveborn you're
able to bolster these skills at the cost
of your health additionally a critical
hit focus stabo mancher who runs cold
with the berserkers melee talents can
strike from the shadows with frigid
ferocity while a spore warden who
combines clawbringer skills with their
offense is a fungal lightning rod of
destructive power these character builds
require a significant investment of time
to truly reach their peak but once
you've reached a high enough level and
you've found the right foot they're
creatively chaotic with the devastation
that you can reach admittedly each fate
maker class pales in comparison to the
flexibility of borderlands 3's vault
hunters but the gear you randomly
acquire mostly fills this gap there's an
element of chance to all of this though
so the odds of spending hours hunting
for that one legendary that perfectly
slots into your current character build
can be a tiresome grind with a level cap
of 40 you'll have to think very
carefully about where you want to apply
your limited number of skill points
across those two character classes while
you'll have to consider which base class
you start the game with you'll never be
locked into your secondary class as a
respect machine in bright hoof is always
available for a modest fee of course
like borderlands 3 and its impressive
expansion episodes wonderlands also
sports some scenic vistas to explore
each location still follows the atypical
borderlands environment design template
of long stretches you'll sprint through
before you reach an arena in which to
apply your deadly fate maker trade and
you can bet your favorite d22 die that
each location has a few secrets to
uncover although these boil down to
audio logs and secret dye that can
marginally increase your luck at finding
better loot all of these locations are
inspired by decades of fantasy material
drawing from the fantasy genre to create
caverns that are home to rampaging
trolls spooky beaches populated by
phantom pirates and forests filled with
homicidal mushrooms all of these areas
are linked together by the overworld a
slice of tabletop tourism that has even
more explorative elements to dig into or
side quests to engage in and secrets to
uncover considering that wonderland has
no vehicles for you to collect and pilot
the overworld essentially functions as a
means for quick travel and discovery
where you can pick up more side quests
and take part in and grind for
experience points in dungeons dotted
along the map while it's charming in
demonstrating gearbox's love for classic
role-playing games it's ultimately
pointless in the wonderland's end game
wonderland picks up a few bad habits
from borderlands 3 and it's story and
how it tells its tale there's tonal
whiplash that you'll have to deal with
regularly as the game repeatedly shifts
from lighthearted fantasy fun to
bickering party members dealing with
personal issues that threaten to derail
the entire tabletop session when
wonderlands focuses on the absurd
imagination of tina wonderfully brought
to life once again by the energetic
voice performance of ashley burch it can
be hilarious fun to sit through there
are moments that recapture the silliness
of borderlands 2 like mr tork's
barbarian character casting a magic
intercontinental ballistic missile spell
powered by friendship or clap chap's
various side quests that always end with
disastrous and hilarious results these
are juxtaposed by an effort to recapture
the emotional beats of assault on dragon
keep but the clumsy execution of
haphazardly inserting drama feels
jarring at best even with the assistance
of a great villain brought to life by
the gravelly vocal talents of best
batman will arnett these moments of tina
building a world where she can vent her
insecurities and fears falls flat
wonderland focuses on tina's fear of
being abandoned by her friends and new
family it's content that has the
potential to be a heartfelt exploration
of tina but any exploration of these
themes are briefly touched upon before
being jettisoned into the void the story
content itself dips into borderlands bag
of parody self-referential humor
internet memes and tina's ability to
create new word chimeras on the fly in
her general dialogue if you weren't a
fan of the style of cheeky humor in the
borderlands games well the
fantasy-fueled satire is unlikely to win
you over either credit to gearbox for
going all in on these jokes though
remember only you can prevent sporous
spires
with that the corruption was number
as wonderland's unashamedly skewers the
genre it's set in with quests that range
from goblin liberation to helping a
steam-powered version of claptrap find
his sultry navigating voice the most
modest campaign length which is home to
a handful of superb boss fights is
bolstered by a number of side quests
that vary in length in typical gearbox
fashion the entire fantasy genre is
parodied with the missions you'll be
able to engage in which include helping
a band of goblins fight for their rights
assisting garrett of trivia while he
constantly berates you and the odd bout
of demonic possession don't expect major
changes to the mission structure as a
typical wonderland's quest consists of
reaching a location annihilating
anything with even a shroud of hostility
listening to some more exposition and
then repeating the formula it wouldn't
be too grating if the rewards at the end
of these missions made the repetitive
grind worthwhile but the prize for the
slog through dangerous territory is
usually mediocre gear at best wonderland
even ventures into roguelike territory
with the chaos chamber a selection of
gauntlets that offer plenty of loot cash
and experience points to acquire if
you're prepared to increase the
challenge in each stage and face
escalating opposition along the way just
like borderlands 3 you can even take the
elements from the chaos chamber and
apply them to the lands that you've
previously explored in what wonderlands
calls chaos mode for even more
opportunity at increasing your fate
maker's power chaos mode modifiers
transform wonderlands into a more
challenging game buffing enemy health
resistance and the damage that they can
unleash on you while also adding other
additional challenges each chaos mode
level offers bonus experience points and
better loot if you survive but the only
way to increase those numbers is by
successfully completing a run in a
specific iteration of the chaos chamber
the chaos chamber distills the entire
game experience into a single 20 to 30
minute gauntlet of danger as an endgame
experience it's a fun and snack sized
version of wonderland although its
appeal will likely only have staying
power for players who are looking to
create the ultimate fate maker build as
a spin-off tiny tina's wonderland
doesn't reinvent the borderlands wheel
with this shift towards fantasy that
bears a chaotic neutral alignment
instead it explores familiar territory
that repeats the best and worst of the
borderlands formula and it doesn't
venture out of its comfort zone that
makes for a game that is packed with
solid first-person shooter action and a
competent multi-class system for
creating an interesting fate maker tiny
tina's wonderland re-treads the same
mechanical and narrative grounds as
borderlands 3 ultimately creating a
chapter in the franchise that's fun but
forgettable
oh yeah sure yeah i'll tell them yeah
okay so um she says you are the bravest
fatemaker the wonderlands has seen in
generations but though you have pushed
back the dragon lord's attack his
downfall can only be brought about by
one thing
you must go
and retrieve
the sword of souls i was getting into
that